[Musique]
c'est sa première campagne mais florence
grands juges semblent parfaitement à
l'aise au contact des passants le 11
juin la candidate de la république en
marche est arrivé en tête des résultats
dans la 12e circonscription des yvelines
mais derrière ce sourire confiant se
cache une victoire modeste
rien n'est gagné c'est à dire que tant
que les choses ne sont pas faites il
faut savoir rester humble il faut savoir
rester un modeste et puis et bien sûr
les urnes qui parleront qui parleront
dimanche c'est qu'ils espèrent
confirmeront les résultats du premier
tour
on est satisfait du résultat du premier
tour bien évidemment mais avec un taux
d'abstention qui est important un taux
d'abstention qui avoisine les 48% dans
cette circonscription
l'enjeu du deuxième tour sera donc de
convaincre ceux qui n'ont pas souhaité
se déplacer aux urnes à poissy le
républicain david douillet poursuit sa
campagne il a récolté moins de 28% des
voix au premier tour
un résultat décevant mais le député
sortant reste combatif
la stratégie pour ce second tour c'est
d'être le plus possible sur le terrain
pour essayer de faire comprendre qu'à
parlementaire ce n'est pas qu'une
étiquette c'est aussi une personne voilà
une personne qui doit aller qualité pour
représenter son territoire dans une
démocratie le phénomène d'avoir une
position est quelque chose de sain et
d'obligatoire quelle que soit sa taille
mais une position doit être présent pour
remettre en question les choses
moi je suis quelqu'un qui se bat pour
mes idées qui se bat pour mon territoire
et je me suis tout le temps pleinement
investi je me battrai pour lui jusqu'au
bout un deuxième tour qui s'annonce
difficile mais malgré leurs différences
de programme
les deux candidats s'accordent sur un
point que les électeurs se mobilisent
dans les yeux
[Musique]